好 剛剛特別有提到一件事情
台股不能獨自美麗
我們在這邊是要等美股跟上
而美股大有表現
當然也因為這個禮拜
還有所謂的川席會
給了美股也蠻多的希望
但是這邊就要來請教鐘哥了
我們的外交訂單
下午出爐了
再說歷史新高
外資的空單其實有慢慢的回補
你覺得是好現象
所以10月是看好的
你今天幫我們鎖定Q4高勝率
以及你的黃金交叉量增幅
對 其實這個禮拜除了這個廉價之外
我覺得這個特殊的經濟事件並沒有太多
其實上個禮拜已經過
上禮拜我覺得算是魔王州
魔王州喔
對 就是BOJ
還有這個四五日
還有這個FED升息
那其實對這個美股跟台股
都沒有造成太大的殺傷力
那我們來看這個禮拜可能會遇到什麼事情
那一樣就是924
這一天是禮拜四
那川席會
黃仁勳 庫克 奧特曼
馬斯克跟皮薩
皮薩阿里大家可能比較熟悉
Alphabet
就是Google的老闆
所以帶了這麼大的科技巨頭陣仗去那邊
當然有三大議題
第一個關稅是否能夠休戰
11月10號原本是要到期
然後AI晶片跟稀土
那稀土掌握在中國
AI晶片主要當然就是美國在控制
是否能夠銷進去
所以我覺得兩方牽制之下
這一次大概就過個場
我覺得大概就一世性了
就大家就是和樂融融
那對大盤其實不太會有殺傷力
但我覺得往上可能也沒有
就是大概就是大家聽一個川習會
一個名詞這樣子
不過這兩天美股的AI股市復活
然後川普也有特別提到
有AI的部隊
要認命AI的沙皇
然後說會前會兩邊
對AI的看法也談得很好
我覺得多少氣氛上有點...
氣氛是不錯
但其實大家對川普的言論
我覺得也沒有什麼太大的感覺
包括美股對美國的經濟數據
也沒有太大的感覺
好 那我們先來看一下
台灣實質面
我們剛才左邊都在講口水
右邊就在講真的東西
今天下午公布的8月的外銷訂單
1030億美金
其實上個月只有多少
上個月大概應該是不到1000億
900多
對 900多
所以不論是月增MON或是年增YOY
都是相當的強勢
但我們知道基本面好
可能股市半年前就開始反映了
所以2026 1月1號到現在
其實股市還是持續往上
當然7月遇到一個下彎
我想很多人都知道
重挫就是要買
當然現在看起來都對
但是7月你不一定敢買
這就是人性
所以股市一直在考驗人性
我們從這個既然基本面好
那你就等
假設大家都說中秋變盤對不對
如果下禮拜一真的中錯
一開盤跌2% 3%
當然你還是站在買方比較對
我覺得應該不會變盤
雖然很多人喜歡談這個議題
好 我們來看這個裡面當中
誰變化最多
當然就是最好
資訊 通信 100%
電子產品 83%
這兩個獨佔凹頭
這跟什麼有關
當然還是跟AI 半導體相關
伺服器 晶片等等
都在這個範圍當中
我們反而是要特別留意一下
像2月份這邊有凹下來
主要還是跟應該過年是有關係
如果你看到後續從這個
第四季以後
90 11 12
如果有看到這個往下的趨勢
你才可能假設賺太多的股票
可能可以稍微逢高拔檔
否則大家都不太需要去管它
當然像基本金屬機械
這種傳統產業的
也算是還不錯的年增率喔
所以才能一起創下千億元的外銷訂單是 所以整體來說都是等於從AI相關有外溢到例如說一些電力設備其實都還不錯好 那基本面好
我們再來看一下這個技術面跟籌碼
台紙其實這一波在
我上次來應該是兩週前
其實盤是不好的 它是往下走
我們看到當時的散戶也都在做多
所以我們那時候是說
可能要等一下 我說是盤整
好 我們看最近
最近3 4天
第一個散戶的空單開始翻空了
散戶空單最好就是能夠複製
像今年4月份
我們看到這一串對不對
散戶支付在做空
大盤大漲
所以現在也又來了
在中秋節前後散戶翻空
雖然說今天的空單是回補
因為它停損
它昨天其實有2萬口
今天剩下4500口
因為今天一開 開很高
它可能有點害怕到 嘎到
所以它這邊開始慢慢的
把空單回補
這個對大盤有點扣分
但是我們從這個架構來看
它還是空單
所以一樣是對多方是有利的
再來我們看這個外資
外資從這一波的低點這個位置
你看它的這個空單
是緩緩的補上去
很緩
它緩到幾乎是讓你看不出來
一千口一千口這樣做
但是你看後續
這一波上來
其實外資是現貨買很多
它買了4000億以上
所以代表現貨是比較重要的
期貨一直都是在做避險
如果期貨開始回補空單
就會有軋空
軋空力道的話
大盤你說要供這個高點
這個是台子期
供它我覺得第四季
輕鬆就可以達到
對 今天是現貨過
其實台子期還沒有過前面的高點
這邊有到49000多點
對 所以現在現貨過 期貨沒過
如果你看這個價格發現的功能的話
代表大家還是稍微保守
就是廉價前
它覺得暫時沒有那麼快能夠供過去
所以這是籌碼面
再來我們看資金
這個指標一樣
我們上次來講的時候是綠色
這個我們看美國
納斯達克跟稻窮的這個強弱市
我們上次來應該是9月的時候
那是綠色對不對
綠色 所以大盤是
大概就是盤整
而且整個8月都是綠色
對 如果是綠色的話
代表錢是放在這個防禦型的稻窮
我們看在昨天
禮拜一翻成紅色
迎接中哥的到來
所以納斯達克
不敢說他迎接我
納斯達克開始大漲
然後我們就要留意一下
美國的錢現在留到科技股
但是台灣還沒有 要留意一下
台灣的指標日線還是綠色
小時線兩個市場都已經翻紅
但是如果看這個日線的話
台灣還沒有 可能要再等幾天
萬萬沒想到今天是創高
卻還沒有
對 這是資金嘛
好 如果這個錢還沒有回到這邊
我們來看我們最喜歡看的外資
投信的買盤
對 就是營收好的我們抓40%
然後投信最近一個月
持股超過150檔
兩個條件很嚴格
剩下6檔
就全台灣剩下6檔
6檔
他這邊寫8檔
還想投讀2檔 但是6檔
對 那可能小編自己有2檔要放進去
沒有 我們就看6檔
好 我們看這6支股票
那我教大家一個簡單的方式
我們看DMI指標
好 DMI 什麼時候要再交一次
很多觀眾留言說還真的忘記了
DMI它就是你會看到紅色線跟綠色線
如果紅線在上面你就做多然後搭配一條10TNG線如果同時站上的話它就是最好的買點例如說我們看創意好了我們看這3443的創意對不對好 那你往前看DMI在哪邊黃金交叉
這邊嗎
是不是在這個地方
對
好 那有沒有在月10天均線上面
也有嘛
所以那邊你就都很適合去買進它
在這一塊
因為它這邊已經剛好是黃金交叉了
對
那當然這個趨勢走出來
它就會一路一直擴散上去
它是強勢
對 那我們比較害怕什麼
害怕就是兩條線一直在糾纏
像這一塊
糾纏
對 它就是紅線跟藍線一直在穿來穿去
那就是多空其實沒有什麼趨勢
就是這一大段
那你就很容易受傷
然後就開始去咒罵張林中說
你講這個根本就不準
因為沒有趨勢就是會這樣
我們要找這種黃金交叉的好不好
黃金交叉現在看起來超級準耶
這邊 這邊
都是一些起漲點
對 所以這6檔裡面
現在看起來是四毫兩壞
其實沒有全面的翻多
這跟以前我們在大多頭看到的
這個架構也不太一樣
這樣可以留意一下
比較差的話
我們看藍色還在上面的話
大概就是
台光電
對 台光電
台光電還是藍色在上面
然後旺系現在藍色剛穿上來
對 所以這兩檔看起來比較弱勢
其他這4檔看起來
其實狀況都還不錯
好 不過剛剛明漢有把旺系打氣
探偵系列
明年真的很好
是 好
除了那六檔之外
我們來看一下傳統Q4
我們有做過一個研究
如果你10月買股票放到3月
過去25年
平均的漲幅是8.5%
25年
另外一個半年
就是你4月買股票
然後到9月賣股票
然後這個報酬率大概是0.82
所以兩個差了滿多的
聰明如你 你要選哪一種
趕快買 放到明年3月
所以就是10月初買股票
大概3月底賣是最好的
好 除了這個半年半年來區隔之外
我們來看Q4的特性
剛才這個明翰老師有講過
上漲機率66到80
漲幅3.7到4.9
所以第四季都不太適合去賣股票
當然你可以聚焦一些電子供應鏈
AI相關等等
好 我們也特別的找了一下
Q4勝率比較高的
古期的標的 怎麼找呢
對 大概有這些
台積電這個我想大家也很清楚
應該每個人都有
台積電跟0050
0050 對 這個是一對的
然後像這個漢唐 中信金
聯發科跟廣達
這些也都可以參考一下
這些是歷史上Q4上漲機率非常高的
非常高的 對
除了這個左邊這一塊
就是我們看那個勝率之外
右邊就是看KD
KD黃金交差不容易發生
但只要發生又配上行情大的話
其實都還滿有機會的
一樣這三個條件我們常常在講
我想大家應該都會背了
好 請您再講一次
對 好 我們講三個條件
第一個 股期的量要有
要不就500口 1000口 2000口
這幾個條件再選
這第一個就是你的量要出來
第二個 股價超過10天均線
而且均線正在向上
斜率往上就是多方股票
如果是往下的話
最好不要去買進它
第三個是KD黃金交叉
交叉不容易
這個大概一天只能出現一次所以三個同時符合最近一兩天其實只有這幾檔符合全台股只有這四檔出列了而且滿多是熱門的
友達這兩天超熱
你用這個方式
不論它在哪一天
突然要爆發的時候
它一定會被你抓到
它就像是你在守株待兔
在樹洞外面等
它要跑出來
你就看到它跑出來
我們舉個例子
臉巴勾想它已經創高了
就這個DMI的角度來看
其實
我們是不是錯過它了
已經錯過一段時間
大概在這個位置
大概就是8月底 9月初的時候
我們錯過它怎麼辦
因為它這邊黃金交叉
好 那如果我們不想要追高
那也沒關係
我們就去等
等它稍微靠近時間均線一下
正常應該還是會有機會
可以稍微等到
然後這是聯發科的一個狀況
這一段都在盤整
然後這一段就在那邊糾結
對 那中信金也是一樣
其實最好的買點在這個位置
也是9月初
那對過來看就是在這邊
所以現在看起來好像也過了
現在有點靠近了
這個其實中心金的機會
慢慢的出現
好 大家學起來
只要回檔的時候
再度出現這個紅線往上的時候
就可以來運用了
對 或是下次遇到股災
對啊 股災的時候一定是
一定是藍色會在上面
像這樣 像你看漢堂
漢堂你看這邊是不是藍色在上面
一直到最近 有沒有
那你看這一段
你買這個漢堂
會不會很不太舒服
照理說是不舒服
你看現在有點起來了
機器比較低的狀況
其實可以去參考它
相對可能有機會
再來你看這個廣達
廣達也是一樣
我覺得它也算是比較溫吞一點
你看從這邊到這邊
都是屬於一個糾結
但現在紅色在上面
所以這個也可以去留意一下
可是因為它這段時間一直交錯
是不是要等它稍微拉大一點
你可以看它跟這個均線
如果說這個突然衝上去
像最近的這個風測就有這種味道
衝上去的話
你去追低根
我覺得都還來得及
好
除了這個之外
我們來看剛才說那個KD
我們說在速動外面等對不對
像你看聯電
聯電在這一天
它就衝出來就被抓到了
沒錯
KD51下黃金交叉
而且它是第一檔黃金交叉喔
對 它在8月25號去
我們就會發現聯電可能會發動
這邊大概到現在是28%
景碩大概是在
一樣是8月初
對 8月3號這邊
第一檔黃金交叉
對 當然我們的交叉
它沒有在管基期啦
我們只管交叉
但是不管怎樣
你都會把它找出來
這是過去
現在的話比較符合的話
像這個友達
友達在昨天是黃金交叉
它是偏高檔的
它在50以上
你看今天的開盤
如果你追的話
其實這個肉比較少一些
因為這個紅棒看起來
相對比較少一點
當然你看另外一個是
這個2605的新興的期貨
好 桿莊
對 昨天交叉
今天是黑棒
所以你可以留意一下
這個機會可能就會來了
對 再來最後一檔是這個連帽
同國基板 前兩天遇難的
對 這個黑棒就是
它那個鬼故事發生的時候
其實鬼故事之後慢慢的往上走
KD在這邊它有一點黃金交叉
所以你用這個方式
不論它是這個漲多壓回
或是從第一檔漲上去
其實你都可以去找到
不過廉價的
中哥會用這個台子期避險嗎
當然你要
台子期避險的成本比較高
你要的話可以學雲翔哥
你就買一些簡單 買一些便宜的put
它是比較適合的
好 現在恐怕沒有太便宜的put
可以買
對 因為現在那個權利金比較多一點
對 是
非常謝謝鐘哥